on a été les chercher quand il a fallu
défendre notre patrie et ils se sont
fait tuer avec courage nous les avons
tous connu les
[Musique]
anciens depuis le mois de juillet 50
puissant familles campaent illégalement
campe toujours illégalement sur un
terrain vague du 13e arrondissement qui
appartient à la ville de Paris au quai
de la gare ces familles veulent un toit
dans des loges aujourd'hui inoccupé
conflit en passe d'être réglé puisque le
préfet d'Île-de-France Christian
sauterre a réussi à leur faire accepter
un plan de relogement avec bien sûr
l'aide de l'abbé Pierre de son aide et
de son soutien depuis juillet à ses
familles Antoine guellot et les é les
équipes de TF1 nous racontent ce combat
des S logies du qu de la
gare ce terrain aux allures de camp
militaire est occupé depuis le début de
l'été par des sansabris un terrain vague
situé juste à côté du chantier de la la
très grande bibliothèque et du ministère
des Finances l'histoire du 133 qu de la
gare est celle d'une occupation illégale
et symbolique en effet la ville de Paris
avait choisi d'y construire des bureaux
et des logements de luxe toutes ces
familles en grande majorité d'origine
africaine se sont unies au nom d'une
exigence simple un toit un droit avant
d'arriver sur ce campement de fortune
elles avaient été expulsées de leur
logement légalement pour cause de
rénovation ou de démolition des
appartements on est à la rue on n'a pas
de logement euh au chômage non tout le
monde travaille tout le monde et en
situation régulière parce que c'est
c'est moi qui nous avait d'abord ticket
101 familles ont vécu ici pendant près
de 4 mois dans la poussière puis le
froid plusieurs associations se sont
mobilisé pour les aider à tenir le coup
rien n'était simple en effet pour les
270 enfants du campement à trois
reprises la mairie de Paris a même
demandé l'expulsion parlant des
squatters entrés dans
l'illégalité les personnes qui sont là
sont des personnes qui n'avaient pas de
situation réellement de d'urgence c'est
bien pour ça que nous disons qu'il
s'agit d'une opération qui a été montée
de longues mains et nous ne devons pas
créer une injustice au détriment de ceux
qui attendent un logement et qui veulent
un logement mais pour l'abbé Pierre
fidèle soutien des familles il y avait
bien urgence tout simplement parce que
l'hiver 91 s'annonçait rude lundi
dernier les familles criaient victoire
l'État a donné sa parole elles seront
relogées d'abord provisoirement dans ces
baraques de chantier puis définitivement
dans des appartements sociaux en cours
de rénovation mais rien n'est fini pour
autant dans le 17e arrondissement par
exemple tout le monde ne voit pas d'un
bon œil l'installation de nouveaux
immigrés dans des préfabriqués au 133 qu
de la gare on voit pourtant l'avenir
avec sérénité les préparatifs du
déménagement ont commencé les enfants se
demandent même à quelle école ils seront
inscrit pour ces familles l'hiver 91 ne
ressemblera donc pas à l'hiver
54 monsieur laabbé hier il y a donc une
manifestation
manifestation des d'un certains lieux de
Paris notamment dans le 17e des
habitants et des commerçants qui disent
on n'en veut pas de ces familles d'abord
on nous a pas prévenu et deuxièmement ça
va causer des problèmes de
cohabitation et d'implantation de ces
familles comment vous réagissez à cela
vous qui vous êtes battu depuis le mois
de juillet et qui avait réussi à leur
faire accepter comme on vient de le voir
justement un compromis qui vous
paraissait vivable pour tout le
monde je respecte profondément les papas
et les mamans qui ont pu participer à
cette
manifestation mais je ne peux pas pas
maudir ce qui inspire cela il craignent
qu'il a des problèmes de cohabitation
j'ai vu vivre pendant des mois ses
familles et si des problèmes de
cohabitation surviennent aujourd'hui il
proviennent pas d'eux
mais qui leur
disent vous êtes de trop
je ne sais
pas si ceux qui ont participé à cette
manifestation se sont souvenus qu'ils
sont papas
maman s'ils avaient vu comme je les ai
vu se mamans pendant ces 3 mois
accouché là on dit que c'était
illégal toute ma vie j'ai répondu à ceux
qui parlaient d'illégalité de ce que je
faisais lorsque des familles de
travailleurs
avec leur salaire n'ont pas de
possibilité de se loger d'avoir ce
minimum de sanctuaire qui est un logi
permettant la vie de famille alors ce
qui est illégal c'est la loi la loi qui
ne permet pas au travailleurs d'avoir un
logement cette loi-là elle est illégale
et ce que je fais je dis parfois en
souriant ce que je fais c'est ce n'est
qu'une anticipation sur la légalité la
légalité qui s'imposera savez-vous que
j'ai j'ai vérifié les chiffres je les ai
demandé à la préfecture sur les 2
millions de logements qu'il y a
actuellement dans Paris il y a 180000
logements sociaux sur 2
millions la plupart des logements que
l'on bâtit sont pour ce que monsieur
girirac a appelé les classes moyennes
dans la campagne électorale
pour la municipalité les classes moyenne
actuellement ce sont les familles qui
ont 30000 francs par mois
voilà lesquels pour lesquels on fait des
logements dieu merci la loi baisson pour
laquelle nous avons beaucoup travaillé
impose à toute ville y compris Paris
désormais d'avoir pour tout programme 10
% de logement sociaux de logements
sociaux et on m'a dit que dans le
dernier mois la commission compétente
pour la ville de Paris s'est réunie
trois fois en un mois ce qui ne serait
pas arrivé s'il n'y avait pas eu ce choc
qui a été donné par ses familles alors
on là là il s'agit même pas de
construction de logement il s'agit de il
y a des logements log log par nous avons
eu la naivité de croire et l'ignorance
de croire que ce qu'on a appelé le
décret de 1945 prévoyant le droit de
réquisition pour les préfets en cas de
crise grave c'est la crise grave quand
il y a des bébés qui vont être dans la
rue bien or depuis la loi de
décentralisation le Pr le préfet ne peut
que proposer et c'est la ville qui doit
décider je n'ai aucune hostilité contre
la ville actuellement
géré par ceux qui la gèent j'ai même de
l'amitié pour plus d'un de ceux qui sont
responsables monsieur Tibé je l'ai eu au
téléphone il y a 2 jours et 3 jours et
j'ai de l'amitié pour lui mais je je les
comprends d'ailleurs les élus municipaux
ils savent que dans leur fichier j'ai
vérifié ça aujourd'hui ils ont plus de
60000 demandes de logement pour des gens
qui habitent déjà dans Paris qui
travaillent déjà dans Paris et qui sont
chez les parents chez un ami et cetera
et sur les so 60000 il y en a plus de
30000 qui sont catalogués en
rouge
urgent bien je comprends très bien que
les responsables disent mais si nous
nous donnons logement à 100 familles qui
sont venus camper sur un
terrain les les 30000 autres diront cux
qui ont eu raison et on va les réoccuper
le terrain il a fallu que nous
promettions que on démontrait les tentes
aussitôt qu'une famille serait dans un
passerelle comme on dit en attendant
logement définitif logement préfabriqué
en attendant unement voilà nous avons
obtenu à cette occasion une chose très
importante et c'est la Fondation pour le
logement des pues défavorisés qu'on a
appelé depuis 4 ans fondation abépierre
ce qui me gêne mais c'est cette
fondation qui a obtenu un contrat avec
l'État le ministre est ven me
l'apportter à domicile à Charenton
contrat qu'on appelle contrat d'objectif
où l'État a déjà mis les crédits pour
que l'on réalise en 3 ans 600 logements
pour les plus défavorisés pour on les
plus bas ça l'air les plus bas revenus
600 logement pour l'agglomération
parisienne et Paris est les la zone
desservie par le métro n'est- pas et
c'est la fondation qui a obtenu cela si
les ces familles alors il y a deux
choses que je veux dire parce que je
veux rendre justice honneur à ceux qui
le méritent si ces 3 mois il a été
possible que ces familles ne désespèrent
pas ça a été au grand en grande partie
pas eux seuls en grande partie à mes mes
compagnons des communautés des Maus ce
sont ceux de ne plaisance la puisance de
nos communautés qui ont tout pris sur
eux l'argent les couvertures les lits et
cetera et on m'a demandé de le redire je
tiens le redire pour tout ce qui est
veut se couvrir du nom de Emmaus ou de
l'action de l'AB baé pierre il n'y a
qu'un seul organisme reconnu par emus
international c'est l'organisme qu'on
appelle Emaus France qui a la
responsabilité de la coordination et des
9000 logements de la HLM emus et des 104
communautés en France avec 4000
compagnons et c'est important qu'on le
sache le dernier point et les familles
qui étaient là toutes étai en règle avec
permis de résidence permis de travail en
règle de loyer et ils ont ils ont tous
un travail en plus il faut le répéter
tous ils ont été dehors il y en a neuf
qui sont des employés de la Ville de
Paris qui ramassent les poubelles
messieurs dames vos poubelles à vous qui
avez manifesté contre eux c'est il y en
a neuf ils seront relogés la maie de
Paris a dit qu' s engagé par priorité de
les reloger espérons bien mais il faut
ajouter que c'est vrai que le plus grand
nombre pas tous mais le plus grand
nombre étaient des familles noires et là
je veux recrier la la stupidité
révoltante
de se refuser à être frère avec eux on a
été les chercher quand il a fallu
défendre notre patrie et ils se sont
fait tuer avec courage nous les avons
tous connus les anciens et à la GU 14 et
à la dernière guerre et après quand la
guerre a été fini on a été les chercher
par bateau par charter entier pour plus
vite déblayer nos ruines plus vite nous
redonner la les agréments de vie
alors s'il y a et l'industrie je dis
s'il y a risque de de conflit de
cohabitation c'est pas d'eux que viendra
le risque il viendra de nous les les les
j'allais dire les bourgeois je suis
d'une famille de bourgeois le bourgeois
c'est quelqu'un de très honorable c'est
quelqu'un ordinairement qui a été
travailleur économe et qui mais qui
après a tellement eu à peiner pour
donner cette sécurité à sa famille que
il a tendance àre refermer sur lui alors
c'est de de ceux ceux qui ont déjà le
nécessaire que risque de venir le
conflit de cohabitation j'ai admiré dans
ces familles
leur comment dire la le le respect la
dignité qu'ils ont montré l'attachement
à la vie de famille disant nous aimons
mieux mourir hommees femme enfant plutôt
que de nous voir séparer quand on a
parlé de prendre les enfants par pitié
et de les enlever aux parents c'était
extraordinaire de voir cette force de la
l'amour
[Musique]
familial